uh good evening
ladies and gentlemen members officers
and members of the public can i welcome
you to this
planning meeting of the 21st of july uh
also welcome councillor keane who's
new with us tonight down there the
wing i pick up why did i say king it
started off well there
beg apart and that was my fault as well
um
no sorry right as always housekeeping
members
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices
via the stairs where you came in
either through the security door which i
always say this is to my right
behind charles use the corridor
please do not use the lifts and assemble
in holy square
on the green where officers will assist
you when it is deemed safe
for you to return to this chamber
does anybody intend filming this meeting
can they please put the hand in there
i can't see any thank you
move on to right restrictions obviously
of mobile phones but
everybody present please ensure that
their mobile phones
are turned to silent and they are not
used to make
or receive phone calls in the chamber
while this
meeting is in progress and just
let members and the members of the
public know we are being live streamed
as the meeting takes place
[Applause]
members requesting to speak under
council procedure 20.1
councillor breedwood gregory farance
and scott and that is on item
of land of north west and south east
sides of
shotenbe road if there is any other
member
who hasn't i haven't called out speaking
tonight could they let me know please
and that's obviously apart from the
committee thank you members
public speaking the foreign applications
have been reserved for public speaking
members please make a note uh the follow
items on their agenda
agenda item 6a
which is a01 of the forest is arms in
boundary road 48 boundary road ramsgate
also
at gender item 6d d04
49 some peters road
agenda item 1 i have apologies from
councillor paul moore and he is
substituted by
councillor phil fellows are there any
other apologies
thank you councillor ozeki has sent his
apologies thank you
item two um declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest
which i know there are thank you very
much uh councillor hart
has declared interest in item 6b
which is 32 shakespeare road
uh yes can we yes
my house where i live i thought it was
um so therefore as members know and
members of the public
if any member of staff or members of the
council
have an application in front of us or
submit an application
uh obviously they declare interest and
um i will ask council heart to leave the
chamber
agenda item three minutes of the
planning committee which was held on the
23rd of june
uh do members agree that the minutes or
the planning committee
meeting held on the 23rd june 2021 be
approved and
signed by myself now i believe there is
a query
counselor gala thank you yeah i just
want to question um
the on page 1920 it hasn't
um minuted the fact that we
refused the application on shot and dean
mode and asked for
um it to be officers to come back with
the
document reasons for that refusal but we
actually
agreed that that was refused so i think
it should be minuted
um i will turn to miss livingston or
jane
yes sorry yes sir mr lewis
the the discussion and the motion that
was put forward
by myself which was then um repeated
um and outlined in a in a slightly
different way
was to bring back to consider reasons
for refusal members i think and again i
i'm not going to necessarily speak for
members and members can can can speak
about this or not wasn't
to confirm refusal with regards to
reasons it was to consider the reasons
for refusal
and obviously the main issue was that it
wouldn't be sensible to vote for refusal
without actually having any reasons to
refuse it
in terms of the detail of those reasons
which is why obviously the motion was
put forward
or suggested is put forward from from
the chair here
are you happy that counselor um well not
not really because we we did actually
make it quite clear among all of
ourselves
that that we refused the application
the reason it was deferred was because
we couldn't agree amongst ourselves
the actual document there is reasons for
that refusal we spoke about all the
reasons and i think we agreed
a lot of the reasons but we were asking
for it to be documented in such a way
that it could be um that it could be a
good
agreed formally but there was no doubt
that we
agreed to refuse the application
uh thank you council i'm going to ask
our to
come back to you thanks very much
thanks very much council ghana the
difficulty is as mr livingston has said
you can't refuse without clear reasons
so
to understand what you're saying but in
order to
collate those proper reasons and to go
away and get some
coherent reasons that was the proposal
put forward from the chair
to defer four reasons for refusal and so
you've got a report
today before you with some cogent
reasons for
for refusal and then an explanation of
why some of the other reasons for
refusal wouldn't be appropriate and then
there's some additional information on
there
relating to a letter that's come forward
from gladman's
so it is appropriate for you to consider
that report before you
if you're still considering refusing
then obviously looking at the reasons
for refusal because you can't make it
it's very well you can but it's quite
risky to make
a decision to refuse without reasoned
reasons because legislation guidance
says
you must have reasoned reasons so that's
why
the motion was put forward worded that
way last time
it's a nuance but that's that's why
thank you
okay well okay as long as it's
understood and i think we all understand
that when we have the debate on the shot
and dean road tonight
it is around agreeing what those reasons
are
for the refusal which we agreed at the
last planning committee
i understand also understand what um the
cell has stated here counselor ghana
thank you thank you for bringing that up
though and hope you've got the right
explanation there
um so therefore um i do propose that the
minutes
um are correct for the meeting on the
23rd
of june good night
i pick up on it's been explained to
councillor ghana and i can understand
the reasons why
council garners question has been
brought and i feel that has been
answered correctly
uh will council ogana's um comments and
question be minuted for tonight
i'm sure they will be yes yes
thank you so therefore can i have a
proposal at the minutes with the slight
alteration
or edition um
we'll um go ahead poser please
counselor coleman cook can i have a
second to please
i think council heart members agree
quiet but i will take that as read and
agreed
agenda item for the planning application
for edinan house business center in
addington place i called upon the
planning officer who will now
outline the report
emma
sorry thank you chairman um
the application site is outlined in red
on this plan here so
the um site is adjacent to hartford
place
and backs on to addington place
this is the um existing building that um
members saw
at the previous meeting so this building
here
is for demolition and the proposal is to
replace this building
with five three-story three-bed houses
and one
three-story four bed house so again this
is the building here the l-shaped
building in white and it's proposed to
demolish
this building with a new build
development fronting onto hartford place
so these photos are just remind members
these were um taken
from hartford place so the application
site is on the right hand side here so
it's this
section here from this wall and so this
element here is to be demolished
and then again just parts of the wall so
as members remember
um there was there's flint within the
wall and this was raised as one of the
issues but
i believe members um uh considered that
the the loss of war was not um
a significant concern and this again
is the application site so again this is
this wall here is to be demolished
and then again taken further from the
neighboring properties opposite
looking back at the application site and
then these this is opposite the site in
hartford place these are existing
neighbouring properties so just showing
the
um height and layout of these properties
and then inside the neighboring
properties opposite and then this is
taken from addington place to the rear
so
this is the existing road the access
into the site
is in this location here and this is a
building on the on the left hand side of
the access and you can see the existing
buildings are back onto it so that
currently some are in residential use
and some are in commercial
and this is now inside the site looking
into the rear elevation of the existing
building so the current building
is in commercial use company offices
and the proposal is for residential
and again another view inside the site
looking at the existing building so all
of this
building here would be demolished and
then back
in add into place just looking along the
access road with the application site
being on the left hand side here
so this was the layout plan that members
saw at the previous meeting so this was
um the plan showing the demolition of
the existing building and its
replacement with
the six units so the unit in this
location here is
the larger four bed unit and these five
units here are the three bed units
and there was two parking spaces
associated with the development so they
were located in in this
position here and this building here was
the
refuge store to the rear of the
properties they each had um their own
garden and access
into the parking spaces was via the
existing access point from adding some
place
and then this is just showing more
detail the existing the parking spaces
that were proposed as part of the
previous application
and you can see the refuse store as well
and the elevations
at that on the bottom of this plan this
was the elevation of the proposed
development
so um it showed that there were
two-story units with accommodation at
roof level with a dormer so this was the
elevation fronting onto
hartford place at the top of this plan
and at the rear
um was the rear elevation that you would
see through the access gap
from adam's place and it shows it is a
three-story level
but you would only get a sense of that
through through the access
so when members considered this at the
last committee meeting
i understood that the main principle of
the development of replacing the
existing building with
the residential development was not of a
concern
nor was the loss of the existing flint
wall the main concerns that
members raised were to do with the
number of units and the lack of parking
provision
so um in terms of the uh
sorry this was just the layout plan as
well showing the units and again you can
see the
the detailed garden layout of them so
what's happened is that an amended plan
has been submitted
the amended plan does not show reduction
in units but it does show
um a small increase in parking provision
so
here again is the exist the two parking
spaces that were previously proposed
and now an additional one parking space
is proposed
in this location here which is adjacent
to number 46
addington place so this now provides
three parking spaces
for the six units
um the this parking space here is now
within the blue line
um but that's still within the
applicant's control so this would be
um enforceable and able to be provided
as part of the scheme
so um the main considerations are
whether the the lack of this parking is
is a concern
um policy spo six of the thinning local
plan
is in relation to car parking provision
and it states that proposals for
development will be expected to make
satisfactory provision for the parking
of vehicles
the policy then refers to um
maximum space standards the maximum
space standards for this form of
development
being that it's located on the edge of
the town centre would be
a maximum one parking space per three
bed unit
and 1.5 spaces for the four bed unit so
the maximum parking provision that would
be expected for this site would be 6.5
spaces
and as you're aware there's three
parking spaces provided so it's 3.5
spaces short of the maximum provision
kcc highways have been reconsulted
following the submission of this plan
and asked for further comments
they have again raised no objections to
the provision
they they consider that the site is
sustainably located
it's in walking distance of a bus route
and in close proximity to the town
centre
and given the fact that um it is a
maximum parking sales are not minimum
parking standards
they feel that there is not a justified
reason to object to the scheme on
highway safety grounds
um other considerations of the fact that
the existing building
already generates the need for parking
provision um i'm not quite sure the
of the exact comparison in terms of
floor space but obviously you saw from
the photos that there is
currently um parking provision to the
rear of the units so it's
um but you would have to consider the
the relationship between
the existing situation with that parking
for the commercial units versus the
proposal for the dwellings and whether
there would be an actual increase
the other consideration is the fact the
site lies within the conservation area
so policy sp06 does allow for a
reduction
in parking vision where i think where
the
parking division itself would actually
impact on the conservation area
so again members raised concerns at the
previous meeting
that and there were too many units on
the site and that potentially one unit
should be removed in order to provide
parking provision
this would potentially result in a gap
within
this um length of development now as you
saw from the
uh the images the photos there's
currently
um a full development at the full length
of this site um and that continues
beyond both sides so there's no
gap within the street elevation so the
question would be would a gap in the
street innovation actually be
detrimental to
the conservation area given the historic
layout of the of the site and the fact
that's the existing pattern of
development
so actually from office's point of view
we would actually want to encourage the
retention of
a full street elevation along here and
not actually see any gap
in order to provide parking and parking
will see the the visual impact of
parking on a conservation area it's not
it's not traditional to have um parking
as part of
historic developments and therefore it's
what impact would that have to actually
have a view of parking
and from um hartford place
so on balance given the fact that there
has been
one increase in parking spaces and the
fact that there is
a maximum parking standards the fact
that
kcc highways have raised no objections
to the development
and consider that whilst um there will
be a reduction
of one less than one space per unit this
would actually be more of an
inconvenience for the future occupiers
rather than an actual highway safety
issue
and given that it's a sustainable site
and close to the town centre
it's not considered there's a
justification for refusing the
application
on lack of parking provision so it is
recommended that members approve this
scheme
as set out in option 3.1 which seeks to
amend the conditions for the approved
plans
to allow for this additional parking
space and also the parking
condition um which then now enables the
parking space within the blue line to be
provided as part of the scheme
thank you chairman thank you emma i move
the officer's
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair please second
or second nature thank you councillor
mccook members
counselor
yes con alvin chair thank you
the name's gone you're very welcome
anytime i can help you chair i'm more
than happy to do
um chairman i thank miss phillips for
bringing us back here
um i am concerned about this i was
concerned the last time
um the extra parking space is not within
the development
it's not within the application that's
before us
it's on land adjacent which the which
the
owner of and the developer of the site
owns so
we can't i'm sure we can't enforce that
because it's not it doesn't fall part of
the application otherwise that would be
outlined in red
so can i just ask if the officers can
they confirm that or or
[Music]
thank you chad um so it would be
controlled by the specific condition
in terms of enforceability uh we do
think that if
it wasn't provided it would be a breach
condition notice that could be served
which would cover the blue line land
because it's in the control of the
applicant and so we do think the
condition would cover it
council one do you wish to come back
yeah i'd i'd just find i'm having a bit
of difficulty with this
um we find that we we could
take it not but we can we could anyway
let's move on from that
i don't think there's enough car parking
space here
uh i do believe that the end property
the four bedroom house
is uh just over develops the site if the
smaller house if it was the same as the
other one
you could get parking up the side and
you'd still have it still have his six
houses
you know that's for me is it and bless
kent kcc highways
bless their little hearts but sometimes
they they don't get it right and i think
we'll prove that a bit later on this
evening
and um so i'm on i am concerned about
this chair
and uh and i can't support the officer
recommendation
thank you uh thank you and any other
members wish to speak
councillor keane thank you chair
i wasn't at the meeting when this was
bought before members
previously so this may have already been
answered then
but how exactly are those three car
parking spaces to be allocated is it
just first come first serves
um i believe the intent the intention
was to actually have the two parking
spaces
in this location here were actually
going to be um allocated to the larger
unit
um but i'm not aware who would be
allocated um
this single space i'm afraid i don't
have that information
okay council king council of wing okay
it's okay you didn't call me cancel
album which is
i just need to check what the rules are
for me because i spoke on 20.1 because i
wasn't a member of planning
at that moment so am i now allowed to
speak as a member of planning
okay okay so i spoke quite extensively
on behalf of
a large number of residents who i
believe put planning complaints in and
i i believe that it was discussed that
one unit should just go completely
i don't actually buy the whole car
parking and conservation because our
all of our conservation areas are
absolutely blighted by the number of
cars that are there
so although we've got an increased
allocation of one each of those houses
has a potential to produce
two more cars so i think the whole
conservation and parking is
blown out of the water actually i still
have a concern about the flint wall
we're losing our flint walls it's a very
significant flint wall
but there you go there are gaps on
within that area i know the area very
well i live i live around the corner
there are
different heights and different styles
of buildings within that whole area
partic
particularly addington place and
ellington street
also on nelson crescent we've got
different sizes and styles of of
georgian properties so i also don't get
the whole argument about keeping the
the streetscape uh the same or
not having a gap there or having a lower
bit i'm with councillor alban i think
that whole building at the end should
just go
and i thought that that was what was
suggested go back to the developer and
tell him to remove one unit
so so that's what i think uh thank you
councillor wing
do i see any other speakers at all
councillor hall thank you chair
um i do remember this um and i think
the issue the other issue we had on this
was the fact that people have green
spaces allocated to their houses
and that they might end up knocking the
walls down on the fencing down and then
everybody parking their cars in the
garden so nobody's got a green space
i think that was one of the issues
raised as well and i
i i'm very loathe to accept that
one property has two car parking spaces
and the other five have to fight tooth
and now to get
the last one and no disrespect to
planning
most of us have at least one car in the
family and i don't
think that you've got five people or
five families potentially
fighting over one space is sufficient i
mean if
if the we we did say at the time we
thought that the
developer should remove a property i
mean if the developer wanted to change
the four bedroom detached house into a
flat so you still keep your landscaping
you can park underneath
everybody would be happy i mean he's
still keeping a building there
but people park underneath it and you
have the allocated parking
so i don't see what the issue is it's
just a developer trying to over develop
the land i think
thank you council heart ever
um i just want to come back on the point
um made in terms of
it was expected that a unit would
disappear we did actually go back to the
developer with
members concerns and suggested that um
that one unit was removed and parking
increased this is a plan that we have
before us now so
there was not um you know it was not
intent you know they did not decide to
reduce a unit they just wanted to
increase one parking space and
they just want members to make a
decision based on this plan so
it's not possible to get reduction units
because um they don't want to amend it
i would also say though in terms of
what's been talked about in terms of
parking provision the fact that
you would expect units to have a
requirement for parking spaces that is
true
but the whole the whole point is that we
have a policy that looks at maximum
parking standards because the
government's just encouraging us to look
at sustainable forms of transport
and that is why we have maximum we used
to have a minimum but now we have
maximum
and that's because we're trying to
encourage people to cycle encourage them
to get the bus
and this is located close to the town
centre close to other facilities so
it would be encouraging people to not
have a car i know that's not always
practical but that's what the government
encourages and that's what the policy is
requiring
and that's why it's very difficult for
us to object to applications
on lack of parking where the policy is
looking at a maximum
provision rather than a minimum uh
thank you very much council fellows yeah
thank you chair um yeah i'm agreeing
with everyone else like that
one property needs to be removed for the
parking
i think it's it's it's crazy to think
that four
there's gonna be five family homes one
very large family home
and you're gonna say that four houses
are not going to have a car in the day
and age where everybody has a car and
also a work vehicle
vans in an area with uh where parking is
our premium
you know where where are people going to
park you know
you cannot expect people in large family
homes not to have cars
so this needs to be amended and refused
tonight i think
uh thank you cancer fellows sir
council crinden sorry
okay thank you this is the first time
i've seen this application i wasn't on
planning when it came up before
and i have to agree with pretty much
everything that's been said i'm very
sorry to hear that
um we will be losing the flint wall um
but also this just looks so over
developed and there is such a lack of
green space
and parking on the periphery of the town
centre let alone within the town centre
but on the which is
where this is it's on the periphery of
the town centre
um and i can't see five
four five households fighting over one
parking space
just doesn't work
and i agree with the idea about flats
council bakeford
thank you chair um yes i i was here
before uh when we voted on this and i
we did ask that one um one of the units
be removed
um personally i'm not in the least
concerned about
the flint wall because it's an appalling
state it's like a patchwork quilt
so i don't think i have any concerns and
the building before it's very ugly
but i do feel this is a case of over
development i think
perhaps if the larger unit were removed
adequate parking could be provided and i
think that would be much more
appropriate
so i'm not terribly happy to support
this
application either thank you uh thank
you council paper council right
thank you chairman um i i also got
concerns about
the fact that the lack of parking and
the over development
but in relation to the flint wall um i'm
not sure
if i dreamt this but normally i would
be very surprised if we didn't bring it
up last time that
the flint the flint could actually be
retained and
incorporated into the fabric of the new
new builds
which would retain retain the flint
but also um going back to the parking
there isn't enough parking but there's
nor is there any capacity for a charging
point
thank you thank you council right uh
are any other members wishing to speak
before we take this to the vote
okay members i put this to you those
in favor could they please
show the hands please
those against
any abstentions that motion
is lost uh just bear with me a moment
please
yes mr levinson
thank you chair um so hearing the debate
from members
um clearly the parking is the primary
concern um
you'll see in the report at 3.2
there is an option to refuse the
application on the
basically amended scheme on the grounds
that the proposed number of units would
would not
will not be provided with satisfactory
parking provision to the detriment of
highway safety and highway immunity and
contrary to the relevant policies
that reason doesn't pick up the point
the members are making about the need to
remove the unit
now the question is whether or not
members feel that
there is impact on the actual um
the development in the sense of it being
cramped and congested by virtue of
having a unit
that is that scale at the end if that's
the case
then
then um i think to summarize what
members have suggested
um it would be suggested recommended by
officers that
um members would look to refuse the
application on the ground stated at 3.2
but also by virtue
of the scale and design
of the development that it would result
in a cramped and congested form of
development
contrary to policy qdo2
and and and the conservation area policy
so i wonder if the chair would permit
whether or not anyone would want to
propose a motion on that basis
uh thank you and that's robin
yeah chair thank you um can i just ask
that mr ellison would it be
size and scale or you're just saying
that you know because i think there's so
whether you're meaning the scale of the
building is the size
if you're moving in there i should just
want to clarify that otherwise i want to
read
yeah yeah um yes so
we can we can we can say both scale
i mean they are very similar but in
planning terms they can be taken to be
different things
how about we have them both thank you
so uh therefore if you are having that
yeah
thank you councillor you've heard the
proposal could i have a second to please
several hands going up
okay i just uh i've got it
in the capital letters now of england
again i apologize
secondly by councillor wing do members
agree
thank you members um thank you emma
i believe emery's depart
yes you all wish to vote all agree on
the
yeah okay do you all agree on that
proposal
thank you yes
i am
okay thank you for that members agenda
item five
uh the planned application for the land
of
northwest and southeast of shotendome
road
in margate i will say this once again to
members
and to members of the public
i and members have had a lot of
emails or correspondence from members of
the public
if you don't get an answer every time
that it isn't
to say that we're not looking and taking
the concerns
and some of them are very deep concerns
about all sorts of
matters i think you understand that it's
not that we can't
can't be bothered to do that but i can
assure you
and i hope i'm talking about every
member here do look
at those emails or the correspondence
thank you um speaking under
house of procedure 20.1 uh first of all
can i ask
councillor braver please thank you chair
it appears residents in summit can now
guarantee four things in life
one is death two is taxes three
occasional miss bing collections and
four that members of this planning
committee will be discussing the shot
and down road application
i very much know part of the day that
this application finally gets kicked
into the long grass
like i've mentioned previously we're not
anti-development here in thanet
but we must absolutely put local
residents first
nine percent of fanuc residents are on
low income which reflect perfectly in
our local plan
which suggests that any development over
a thousand square meters
shall be required to provide thirty
percent of the dwellings as affordable
housing
on average earnings for residents in
thanet are in the bottom 20
of the whole of england so this council
not only has a duty to represent local
residents when deciding applications
but it has a duty to represent residents
nationally as well
the lousy 15 percent currently being
offered by this developer is an insult
the fact that can offer a 5 increase in
affordable housing
three weeks apart shows that margins can
be increased when they need to be
but i imagine that greed has a part to
play in this i would also question
why we are meddling and concerned about
the feasibility or
profit that a housing development
company generates
surely that's for them to sort out i
want to thank the planning officers
for guiding this committee for the legal
process that's involved in rejecting an
application like this one
members should have confidence that a
third projection of this application
comes with many valid and sufficient
reasons for rejection
such as breaking with policies on
affordable housing and biodiversity
biodiversity as well as issues on
flooding
sewage and the usual infrastructure
issues such as sufficient access
to gps in addition to this tdc benefit
from an overage agreement on the land
cell
so this application has to be clear
transparent and fair
and to me chair this application is far
from it
i'd like to conclude by reminding
members of a recent high court judgment
which was brought against tdc in the
case they also have a vested interest in
this echoes the fact that great care and
decision making needs to be taken
when deciding the fate of an application
especially when the planning officer
is recommending approval thank you
thank you councillor braywood uh
councillor scott
thank you chair can can i hold you there
councillor scott please um
chief executive would like to have a
word thank you
thank you uh members i i do appreciate
that this is a
very sensitive uh an emotive issue um
but
what i would just like from my members
about the appropriateness of comments
in respect of officers and to try and
avoid
speculation about
decisions that are made and interests
that the council has please
thank you uh thank you chief executive
um
counselor scott if you carry on please
uh thank you chair
um yeah i mean totally agree with the
comments that um
councillor braid would put forwards and
to echo the same um
i mean to take on board just the the
mere allocation of 15
affordable housing um i mean we are in
an area
the priority and essentially we are
deeply bound to actually provide
affordable housing
um from what i've read from a recent
report that um
this potential uplift is based on the
kcc highways um ring road approval and
in my opinion that certainly should not
be the situation if developers are
interested in the land
that they want to develop on they should
meet the terms and conditions of the
local plan that was agreed by the
council
i mean coming back to when i sat on the
planning committee initially for the
first time this actually appeared
in the the committee one of my
main things that i did want to bring up
was the the situation flooding
um i know there has been a flood
assessment but this is all based on the
situation of what we have at the moment
which is
agricultural land which is designed to
develop to obviously soak up that
surface water and yet there is still
flooding once development is on that
that will be a concrete jungle
um of which we're not able to provide
evidence of flooding because
we have not yet built on that but at
that stage it will be too late um you'll
be looking at potentially
housing that could be affected by the
flooding and
we could be pretty sure that these
particular um
housing of affordability will be located
no dear
no doubt by the areas of flooding um
i do remember when we were discussing
that a percentage of the actual
application itself was going to be
designed to have
what at the time was mentioned as a
flood basin
where would there capture any overflow i
called it a ditch
and um at that stage it might have
changed but um
i reckon that real estate could have
been applied for
the housing that they were taken away
from the affordable
affordability um and then lastly just to
basically touch on the infrastructure in
itself which is just
obviously going forwards with the
sewage side of things this this whole
situation with southern water as we all
know
don't know it's um being recent that
even of
17th of june they've had to discharge
wastewater into our oceans um
and yet we're proposing to build more
housing and
the way i see it is if you haven't got
the infrastructure in place
how can you actually build housing
viable that's going to provide sewage
and adequate
drainage for water and at this stage at
the moment
southern water have proven time and time
again that they have not
had that ability 2010 to 2015
they've been charged nine million pounds
to pay into it
i've heard that they were proposing to
put a million into the infrastructure
and yet that hasn't happened so i mean i
i hope today that the um
the planning committee do obviously take
this on board i know that
the focus and the recommendations are to
put forwards on the um the affordability
of housing but i do
really want to push forward that
infrastructure
and flooding is also some issues that
need to be highlighted within this
application i think council scott
speaking as ward councillor councillor
gregory
please
thank you chair much debate
on the developers request to reduce the
number of affordable houses
from 30 to 15 as a consequence the
application was denied and held over for
further discussions with the developers
however the amount of affordable homes
should not be
should be non-negotiable and there are
other issues at stake
this week we have seen the devastation
that flooding
has caused in countries very near to us
we saw only last night areas in west
kent under water
we have a real flood risk locally
there's been no mitigation of the flood
risks that should happen if this plan
would go ahead
since the last planning committee
meeting quite clearly we can expect
a greatly increased volume of surface
water
making its way into tivoli brook from
rain falling on hard surfaces from the
general household surface waste
which may contain chemicals any water
containing chemicals and nitrates
will inevitably make their way into
tivoli brooks and therefore subsequently
into margate
main sands by the outlet again i must
mention
southern waters negligence but also that
water coming down from what was once
fields that soaked up much rain water
this cannot be absorbed by concrete we
hear yesterday of e coli bacterium
found in the coast locally as this
planning application
could have a disastrous negative effect
on the community
can t dc give the businesses
dependent on tourism and the general
public a cast
iron guarantee that increased pollution
into the sea
will not result in the beach becoming
unusable
and nothing less is acceptable we hear
today that tdc were in the high court
defend
defending a development one of the
reasons judge timothy corner quashed
this
at the judicial review was that tdc
had had produced an unsatisfactory
habitat
assessment i haven't seen a habitat
assessment
from tdc regarding the shot and dane
proposal
only one by concerned residents which
lists
many plants insects larger animals dorm
ice brown hairs
that call this area the home their home
this judicial review also found tdc
council gregory i don't like
interrupting any member who's speaking
but
please keep to this planning application
i do know
where you're coming from but we're
talking about the shot and lane
development
thank you
well this is about the shot and doing
development
plea please carry on but um when you
you're bringing in other items which
aren't really
relevant for this for this application
yeah i'm
trying to keep it relevant trying to
keep it relevant
so um the judicial review has happened
and it found that tdc acted in a biased
way and broke its own rules by deciding
this application behind
closed doors of great concern
is a resident who submitted a freedom of
information requests
regarding the proposed shock and dane
development
they asked to be provided with notes and
minutes of any meeting between the
developer
of this site any tdc officer
or any member counselor gregory please
um you're quoting other items
once again this is to do with the with
this application
it's i'm going our
solicitor police to come in i don't say
i do not like
stopping people you have every right to
speak but it's got to be kept
to to this application i i do understand
where
what you're trying to say but i'm
bringing us this moment
but then it'll have to go unsaid
yes i've had advice here and
i'm going to ask carry on council
gregory and then i'm going to ask
how chief solicitors are coming to cyber
wood
thank you
the response my resident got in response
to this
um application for a freedom of
information
requests to do with the proposed shot
and danger
development was as follows tdc
confirmed that they hold the information
that was requested
but were exempt from answering
as councillors we have a duty to
represent
and work in the best interests of
residents they trusted us with their
vote
and trust us to do the right thing for
them their standard of living
their environment for the betterment of
thanit and not to please
outside bodies who threaten that which
they hold dear
it is incumbent on elected members to
think of the electric
electorate and not to blight their lives
by this devastation of the environment
thank you
uh thank you council gregory mister
thanks very much chair thank you very
much councillor gregory i just want to
address the point that's been raised
um well two points really one about the
recent result of the jr at the uh
school at leyland gap um
sorry the uh yeah the people bring jrs
all the time
so people bring jrs against planning
decisions all the time
it's an issue of a point of law so it's
a decision by the high court
on you know how it's been decided it's a
point of law
thing it's not relevant to the
application before you tonight
so the application before you tonight is
clear on the papers
you know the evidence is there and it's
for members to decide that based on the
evidence
not based on what's happened in a jr
matter to do with a different matter
that has all sorts of different issues
that aren't relevant to this
consideration so that's the first point
and the second point about fois
you know we have a duty to deal with
fois and fois are dealt with under their
own body of legislation
again what is raised in an foi request
is not relevant to the consideration of
the application tonight
thanks very much uh thank you um
uh speaking as well councillor council
of parents
thank you chair this application of our
outline planning permission from glad
man developments limited is now before
you for the third time
as you know the applicants will not be
developing the land but selling it on
for development
gladman still maintain that no more than
15 affordable housing is viable on this
site
at the previous meeting councillors
described this figure as poultry and an
insult to both council and
community apparently it isn't viable
because gladman have to make a profit of
20
million pounds am i alone in being
amused by this figure
why could gladman not make a smaller but
very handsome profit and meet tdc's
policies for 30
affordable homes to put this in context
and to quote from the offices documents
before us
currently 29 of our population are on a
low income of less than 16 000 per year
and average earnings are within the
bottom twenty percent of the whole
of england so more than eighty percent
of the population in planet cannot
afford to buy an averagely priced
terrorist house and those who are
renting in the private sector are
spending over fifty percent of their
earnings on living
costs whereas the national housing
federation
identifies that only 30 percent of
england should be spent on housing costs
if anywhere needs maximum affordable
housing than it does
secondly members and officers have
received detailed information from many
concerned residents about the serious
lack of biodiversity studies and
mitigation of this development
and i understand that policy sp30
for sp 30 around providing mitigation
for
farmland birds is being broken there
have been several requests for the
missing bird and breeding bird
surveys to be completed
residents have therefore commissioned an
independent ecology survey
an initial high level of observations
suggest that farmland birds are indeed
present on the site which was apparently
dismissed by the gladman ecologists
our farmland in thanet is possibly some
of the oldest in the country and the
wildlife possibly some of the most
established
for example defra states the
significance of the significance of the
area for lapwing red shank and pawn
bunting
gladman have not managed to record any
of this
in addition local residents in the area
have listed many wildlife
um birds wildlife many
examples which i haven't got time to
read out at the moment but hopefully all
the planning committee have received
that information
it's impressive thirdly
there's the issue of services for the
fifty thousand new residents who may be
coming to planet
currently i'm extremely worried about
the impact of thousands of new residents
being proposed in samston ward
where the gp service is already over
stretched
so that there are sixty thousand
patients per gp against the national
average of about two thousand
the ccg has only made a requirement for
the cost of buildings to meet this need
and not considered medical personnel
but this was nearly a year ago
since then the ccg has stated clearly
that thanit continues to struggle with a
low number of doctors and we have a
fragile
gp system police can officers assure us
that they've gone back to the ccg in the
night of these recent statements for a
few months ago
to ask what actions the ccg is taking to
recruit more gps and medical staff to
ban it which we
so badly need i'm sure tdc cares about
the health of our residents in sanet
particularly when we know that has the
second highest child poverty rates in
the south of
england the highest in kent and margate
has some of the top 10 percent of
deprived wards in
england and wales thank you
thank you parents uh now asked mr
livingston please give his report
thank you um
so the application site in question is
outlined
in red so the application is for uh it's
an outline application for 450
dwellings with road infrastructure on
the allocated site which is in
red in front of you members just a quick
overview of
the key information on the screen
so we've got the the site here an aerial
image
it's either side of shondane road
this is the local plan map which shows
the full extent of the site being
allocated
the areas in yellow are the connecting
parts of infrastructure and the roads
between hearthstone road shondane road
and manson road and this is the
high level parameter plan that has been
submitted with the application
so as a reminder you've got the
areas in green at the areas of open
space
they've been designed around providing
the required provision within the policy
specifically
but also to be able to facilitate the
drainage solution to ensure that raf
doesn't occur on the site in relation to
the built form that's proposed
you've then got in the bottom of the
image in the
hatch area in red that is the
archaeological exclusion zone
where architectural remains were found
so therefore
there's no development pose on that part
of the land and then you've got the
the blue triangle which relates to land
that is safeguarded
for the proposed major road network
development by kcc highways
and the rest of the site is shown in
shades of yellow to indicate the
different heights that are being
proposed so and the report that's in
front of you members
follows last month's committee and the
applications is brought back to members
um with reasons for refusal and to
discuss
the issues that were raised in the
debate uh at the last last month's
meeting
so they covered a number of different
issues um but the consensus of members
and the issue that was raised more than
any other uh was concerned about the
under provision of affordable housing at
15
rather than 20 sorry well than 30
percent
and the report considers this
specifically at
2.3 to 2.8
so 0.2.6 in the report
outlines that the key matter is
what harm results from the provision of
less than 30 percent
of housing whether or not that outweighs
both the evidence that's been produced
by the applicant and ratified by the
council's independent expert
and the other benefits of providing an
allocated housing
site so it's whether or not they
outweigh
those benefits now the reason for
refusal that's been prepared
is outlined at the end of the paragraph
specifically trying to capture the
concerns of members
that were raised to do with the acute
issues of affordability in the district
and picking up some of the points that
were raised therefore that's why it's
referred to the housing strategy
the objectively assessed need to pull
that evidence
forward now as the report goes on to
outline
the office of view is that the viability
evidence
and the compliance therefore because
it's been demonstrated that it wouldn't
be viable
with more than 15 affordable housing
outweighs that specific concern
and then a refusal on that ground would
put the council at risk
if the application was appealed and in
addition the concern is that the under
provision of affordable housing
wouldn't in our view outweigh the
benefits of providing
450 houses on an allocated site
when the council is in presumption in
favor of development
under the housing delivery test and plus
the benefits that are outlined in the
report
to the actual strategic highway network
by providing this route
around coffin house corner the report
goes through
the other issues raised i'll just pick
up some of the points that were raised
in
in the the speaker's comments uh these
are covered at
points 2.9 to 2.13
including flood risk impact on health
care
and impact on biodiversity um so to pick
up the first one with regards to flood
risk
um a flood risk assessment was provided
with
the application that was assessed by kcc
as the local lead flood authority
that looked not only at the existing
surface water flooding that occurs on
the site
but also the strategy of how you deal
with flooding when there are the
dwellings that are proposed
actually on the site that's why there
are drainage solutions that have been
proposed including the attenuation basin
to deal with that issue now kcc as the
local lead flood authority
have confirmed that the strategy is
sound
and therefore the proposal would
actually include a number of conditions
which would secure
the submissions of details when the
detailed layout comes out
to ensure there isn't an increase in
surface water outside the site
as a result of this development and in
the absence of any evidence
to the country it's not considered
therefore as a cogent reason for refusal
on that basis the planning conditions
are there to mitigate that
impact uh and that is the purpose of a
planning condition
and therefore it's our consideration
that an inspector would feel
exactly the same way with regards to the
concerns about the impact on health care
um
this is specifically referred in the
report at
2.11. um the ccgs mentioned
have agreed that a contribution would be
sufficient under the regulations of of
one two two of the of the sil regs
which governs what you can actually get
money for in terms of a planning
obligation
that relates to fixed buildings or
expansions of buildings or equipment
it can't be put towards revenue costs of
staffing
and it's not considered by officers that
there is a directly attributable
impact from the result of this
development uh to result in
the lack of general practitioners in
than it is
it is
it's very clear an evidence in the
report why a code and reason for refusal
cannot be found with regards to that
matter
in terms of impact on biodiversity
there is some issues that been raised
with regards to the lack of a breeding
bird survey
this was directly addressed in the in
the report
last time with regards to um
what they had submitted the applicant
during the
environmental impact assessment there's
a phase one habitat survey
this didn't pick up the presence of
skylarks on site
the application has been referred to
natural england who obviously
decide on which species are protected
and not they have raised no objection to
the development
on the very specific grounds that they
require a condition requiring a
landscaping ecology management plan to
be prepared
at the detailed design stage which is
not what's being considered at the
moment it would be considered a reserve
matter stage
um so at that stage it's about it will
be about getting that plan in
setting the measures for the
establishment and management
of the newly created and retained
habitats there will be an increase in
biodiversity on this
site very clearly evidenced by the plans
that have been submitted
and that has been agreed by kcc
biodiversity and by natural england
in terms of some of the other issues
that have been raised with regards to
contamination again
the officer report that's been put
forward which relays the comments of the
contaminated land officer
as well as the environment agency has
looked specifically at whether or not
there is concern about either existing
contamination on the site
or from surface water runoff and again a
condition was considered sufficient
by the environment agency and also by
the contaminated land officer
in terms of that the last issue with
regards to
drainage um this is specifically covered
in
the the report that's at annex six
members um it specifically talks about
foul drainage and network capacity
as as you'll be aware the provisions of
the water infrastructure act
requires southern water to agree
for a connection to the drainage network
under that legislation
but what they can require and they have
to require is that there is sufficient
capacity within the network
for the dwellings to attach to it and
which is why they will often have a
developer
pay money to upgrade the existing
capacity to cover
that drainage there is a specific
condition
which is would be put on which is put on
all strategic major sites such as this
um which will basically mean that it
restricts occupancy
of the development until sewage
infrastructure is provided
as requested by southern water each
phase would be restricted
in occupation until the infrastructure
for that phase has been agreed and
provided
to ensure that there is no issues with
regards to flooding or indeed capacity
of the drainage network and that is
in compliance with the strategic policy
in the local plan which talks about
drainage
um so to pick up um the other point that
the report covers
um the
the council has received a letter from
the applicant which
is appended to the report
and this is discussed at 3.1 of the
report now
this states that members could defer for
approval
subject to the full 30 affordable
housing being provided on site as well
as
previous obligations and this would rely
on
external funding becoming available or
market changes that would make the
development
viable as time goes on and when it
becomes viable
the 106 agreement by the developer would
then be signed on the basis of 30
affordable housing now this is an option
for members
it's not advised by officers as the
determination would be dependent on
elements which are outside the council's
control as in whether or not the mrn bid
comes forward
or whether or not market conditions are
there so therefore the officer
recommendation
is still to to defer and delegate for
approval as outlined in in 4.3
there's also a concern that it would
open council for a non-determination
appeal
if effectively the decision is not made
and
it's waiting for the submission and
agreement of the the legal agreement
thank you sir uh thank you ian a
detailed report there and i know from
the last meeting a lot of those
um questions uh hopefully for members
have been answered um
uh coming to members if i may counsel
organ
yeah thank you chad hopefully you'll uh
you'll bear with me
um this is extremely difficult
we've got a local plan that says that's
that's been agreed by council
forced it upon us by a government we
have to have a local plan
and this area has been agreed uh for
housing
uh the officers have a difficult task
in dealing with policy
again that's agreed uh and agreed by
government
and they have to they have to follow
those processes
you know the officers are not going to
be here
specifically to say you've got to do
this they've come up with the
recommendation that we either
that we either go along with or we we
don't
um so i wanted to get that out of that
out of the way first
um secondly one of the issues really
that
that really hasn't been fully discussed
him in uh
in my opinion is the um
is the road traffic plan uh laid down by
kent county council
and uh i couldn't attend the last
meeting although i did
foolishly watch it on youtube um
live i said wed i was shouting at the
screen because i wanted a question asked
and no one asked the question and
and i've asked that question of the
local plan manager as to
how and why was this site
looked at and
put in as part of the local plan for
housing
development because it's clear from the
processes that we've gone through here
over the last two meetings and
and this one that this is a difficult
site
to develop so therefore
the uh the applicant this was dealt with
through that local plan process and the
applicant would have known that this is
a difficult site
to develop anyway i'll if you bear with
me
chair i just want to uh just want to
quote
uh someone has come back from the local
plan manager
and which he says and i quote it's
probably worth noting
although it says a background
information
that one of the reasons for identifying
this site in the local plan
was to facilitate the completion of the
inner circuit
which is the uh the highway issue
throughout the site
in line with the transport strategy to
alleviate pressures on the road network
in senate
now i don't agree with that because i
don't think this will and i'll get to
that in a minute
uh in in senate and achieve the
long-term transport improvement
uh public transport uh walking and
cycling blah blah blah
so a major part of this it would seem
to me in this land being allocated
was to ensure that kent county council
can get its it can get its highway
traffic
flow through i would just like to remind
members
who may or may not remember that there
is a development that's got consent
behind samsung grange
now part of that development under the
height through the highway strategy
is that nationally would be cut off to
traffic gate heading towards
westwood this
traffic layout will not solve
the coffin house corner issues it will
create
more and more problems for this area
which will then which will then spread
out and it will affect
everybody in here in fact every
everybody in margate to be
to be quite honest i quite often use the
manchester road coming across from
ramsgate
coming down to uh going down to watson
for some football however the issues of
traffic
coming down from maxton road trying to
go onto shot and dane road
are awful nine times out of ten the
traffic line goes back
past the cemetery and down towards the
mansion tip
so and trying to get out there is a
nightmare i don't think that the traffic
plane that they've got
within this development uh makes that
any easier i believe it will make
matters worse that's my opinion
i also cannot support uh the fact
that we may if and but
get 30 affordable housing if the
developer
gets money from somewhere we can't we
can't do it
we can't have that we can't make this
decision on that basis
so we've got to look at what we've what
we've got and at some times members
we have to take a stand right whether we
lose on a pill
we need to make a stand and i think we
have to make a stand for our residents
we have to make a stand for ourselves
because if i think if we don't do that
in this case if we lose it
we lose it and we know that there that
there would be costs
but this is only an outline application
it's not a full-out full application
so i i really have concerns with this
and and i wish to refuse i will vote to
refuse this chair thank you
uh thank you councilwoman um
i'm going to bring in mr again
thank you just to come back on the the
highways point i think just to give
members some clarity with regards to
actually the development that's shown on
the screen
in fact because they've superimposed the
development at samson grange which has
the resolution to grant
for the link through from nash lane
to um to manston road as council organ
mentioned specifically
that that development would lead to the
closure of the
nash lane arm coffin house corner
with the traffic then routed round
through the local distributor standard
road
to try and reduce the amount of signal
times effectively at the junction at
coffinhouse corner
but in addition that development also
brought forward
a change in alignment and prioritization
at the junction which is mentioned of
shondane road
and manson road that you can see on the
screen next to the listed building here
so at the moment um manson road joins
shondane road
but the the prioritization would change
it would be that shondane road
would join manson road and that
will demonstrably free up traffic flow
through coffinhouse corner
on base of that it's the specific
justification linked to
the development of samsung grange to do
that now
as members are aware in the report it
very clearly goes through in quite a lot
of detail
about the assessment that's been done on
the basis
of transport specifically with regards
to modeling
specifically with regards to traffic
flows both generated by this development
but also the traffic flows currently in
existence around the site
and in terms of that principle of this
having a strategic
route through this site to deal with
that that has been adopted by this
council
it is in the local plan and therefore it
is allocated and
anticipated that that will come forward
and so that principle is is not up for
consideration by members
it's about whether or not the timing of
the roads
is sufficient and again that is covered
in the report in terms of what would be
proposed
in terms of getting a prioritization and
a time frame
forward again at reserve matters stage
because obviously this is as
councillor always mentioned it's an
outline stage so we will be will be
getting more detail
about how many houses are on different
parcels of land
which would relate to different parts of
the routes that are being proposed here
the different links when they need to
come online
that would be part of the considerations
that are still to be made
and therefore it is considered that this
has been looked at in detail by kcc
highways
it was looked at in detail in a local
plan examination
uh and therefore it would bring forward
in in officers views and in the local
plans view
benefits to the road network thank you
chair uh
thank you and before i bring councillor
garnering um
if i may just touch on to council robin
and to mr livingston
it is not nash lane that's going to be
blocked up it is
nash road okay and that's um
having live in that area it is a major
i'm not i don't embarrass anyone but
that is uh
thank you for that chair i i got me
roads and lanes
i know you always do and but it is an
important fact
lane is completely different to um
so thank you i was just waiting to see
who was first to pick that up
thank you yeah thanks very much um i'd
like
like firstly i'd like to start by
thanking
officers who've turned this report
around because i know
we we it was a we put a bit of pressure
on it or a bit of pressure was put on
by some people to turn this around for
this committee meeting and it's been
done so thanks for that
um i agree with just about everything
that
council alban has said especially around
the need for us to make a stand on this
um and in fact that is exactly what we
did
at the last committee meeting we had a
very long debate we covered lots of
issues
and we voted um overwhelmingly
to refuse this application for a number
of the reasons
that are outlined in this report so what
we're here to do today
is to agree what those reasons are
so that we can finally put this refusal
to bed so we don't have to come back to
this we don't have to come back to this
any future committee meetings
now the report outlines a number of the
reasons
i guess in terms of ease
for us the first one around affordable
housing
that's documented in the report and i
suspect
we can all agree to that reason
i take on board what the report states
about
the risk if it goes to appeal but
i think we've said we accept that and so
there's the first reason that we can we
can agree on
i believe when it comes to in the order
that
you spoke about them flood risk
we i sorry i should speak for i said i
understand that kcc have said
we've looked into this and we we think
what's being proposed
and what potential conditions come in
what conditions there are
mitigate this but i don't i
don't agree with it and i don't accept
it
we've seen over the last few weeks when
it rains heavily
tivoli brook reappears and floods
so in effect what we're saying if we
don't if this goes ahead
is that we're um
agreeing an application to build on
tivoli book
which doesn't make any sense to me at
all
and i don't think it makes it sense to a
lot of people
so we should i believe
we should document that as a reason for
refusal
um on the the ccg
side i i understand what's being said
the ccg
have asked for some ask for some money
and it's been accepted that that um or
when they were asked
a year ago um and it's been accepted
that that is
sufficient i and i don't think we
believe it is sufficient
we think it is insufficient and there is
no
we can't i can't agree that there is no
discernible impact
on the care currently being received by
residents in salmon board and this will
have a detrimental effect
i think that is what we will be saying
it will have
a detrimental effect and it isn't
sufficient what they're proposing
and as far as the impact on biodiversity
goes the whatever
else is said the environmental impact
statements
and any other environmental statements
are woefully
inadequate and we've seen from
um a number of different local residents
that there are
we know we know there are various birds
that breed on that site we know there
are skylarks
that breed there we they've been seen by
people and in fact
as has been mentioned um a number of
residents are so concerned about it
that they are they are doing their own
survey to prove this fact and they will
i'm sure that'll be ready to be
presented by the council
by us any appeal that might come forward
to prove actually there were there are
these birds there
and one other thing i just wanted to
mention is the the
the lack of hairs on the side
um apparently there were no hairs there
and i think it might have been i can't
remember if it was mentioned but maybe
we should be asking the police about
this because the police
know there are hairs on the site because
the police are often up there
clearing off illegal hair courses who
wouldn't be up there hair coursing
if there were no hairs and obviously
that
their hair coursing needs to be stopped
because if they keep going on there will
be no hairs but
but they they can provide the evidence
about that so
i believe we've we've refused this
application
um we've we've found we've got these
reasons that i believe we should all
we could all happily agree to
um i know they only it all needs to be
documented a bit more
but i would propose that those reasons
that i've outlined
here are agreed and accepted for the
refusal of this
planning application thank you you
councillor ghana before i bring in
councillor keane um
mr livingston
thank you chair um i think just
to pick up a point with regards to just
taking flood risk
as a point um the derma is not
it's fundamentally not building on
tivoli brook i just want to make that
quite clear tivoli brook is
over 20 meters away it's not related to
this this watercourse is specifically
shown in the flood risk assessment that
it's it's not on this site
and therefore this will not build on
tivoli just to make that absolutely
clear for members
um again this comes down to evidence
this comes down to the fact that there
are it's been modeled
by the applicant very specifically to
look at surface waterfront it's
acknowledged as an issue on this site
it's not being hidden away it's being
mitigated by the development that's why
they're proposing the mitigation
that they're providing and so a refusal
which seems to disregard the information
that's been provided
would be very damaging to the council in
my view
in addition the point with regards to
what the nhs and ccg have asked for
again it comes back to what we can deal
with under planning obligations and what
we can't
we cannot require um more gps to be
employed
by virtue of this application it's not
directly applicable
to a direct link that plan operations
can do it's subject to lots of separate
processes
so i think that is it's really important
to understand that
infrastructure is a key issue
strategically and locally with regards
to this
what planning can do with regards to
infrastructure and health infrastructure
is look at can existing facilities
expand
and then it's the responsibility of the
local care provider
to staff that service it's not the
responsibility of planning to do that
in terms of impact on biodiversity again
i go back to natural england's response
and i go back to kcc biodiversity's
response
specifically looking at what's been
proposed and also very specifically
about the mitigation
that's being put forward and
specifically the landscape and ecology
condition
and just to quote the the report in
terms of the specific
mitigation measures that would be put in
place which would cover
breeding birds on site specific lighting
scheme to minimize impact
on nocturnal animals new homeowner
information packed strength and boundary
vegetation through infill planting
open grassland wild wildflower meadow if
we go back
to the um the the proposal you can see
the open space again which would be
conditioned to provide
additional species and council ghana in
the very first debate we
we talked about that and you obviously
referred to the fact that you know the
biodiversity and horticultural officer
is supportive of the scheme by virtue of
the fact that they are providing more
species
that are currently in situ on the site
there at the moment which will
you know bring forward more biodiversity
impacts habitat enhancement for nesting
birds
in especially on the southwest boundary
of the site including bird boxes
again that provision is within the
application
and therefore to go against that on the
basis of a concern without
and having a full awareness of these
issues would be
again it's a it would be a very
concerning and damaging precedent
on that basis now the report
specifically looks at what would be a
cogent reason for refusal
that would would be able to be argued at
appeal
that's why officers have outlined a
reason for refusal based on affordable
housing
that was a consensus view that members
took it was a concern that was outlined
by the majority of members
and that is why the report has outlined
that specific reason
uh in a bit more detail thank you chad
uh
thank you mr jensen um a couple of
points from me before again i will come
to you council keene i haven't forgotten
you
um if members of the public can keep
their voices down i know this is a very
serious matter for yourselves and your
concerns but
we can hear up the same conversations
quite loud
also um i think it it's fair to say the
reports
that this committee get um obviously
from offices
and not necessarily the recommendations
but we have
detailed reports as we're hearing more
so
on this application but it's the same
even if it's a small application
the officers role is as you've seen
[Music]
to give us as members the report from
all the agencies and who
are involved in a site and
i know we have we have a if i can say a
lot of talent on
this committee and i mean that there's a
people here
who know what they are really talking
about on various subjects of
nature and everything else but we really
must
listen to what and read what is in these
reports because
they are the you know those people are
the top people whether we
agree or not agree that is up to you
but i think it's quite evident that um
i know you have concerns but i think
that must be put to you that
what's in our report has come from the
appropriate people
and we have to take that on board
council keene
thank you chair well i'm going back to
affordable housing
our local plan is supposed to oh sorry
our local plan is supposed to provide
local housing to meet local need and we
need
affordable housing and so how are we
ever going to get that
when it seems no one is prepared to
build them
it says that it's not viable with um any
more
than the 15 we've been offered but
actually
the um profit margin of 15 to 20
they're coming in at 16.97 so almost two
percent
more than the bottom line so actually
there is some room for play
just in that but also i wonder whether
the
bench lock bench mark land value
is correct because i was reading about a
case in islington
which they won on affordable housing
because they said that
the benchmark land value had failed to
reflect the expectation
of 30 affordable housing and therefore
sort of how can we be sure whether our
viability assessment
adequately reflects that in the figures
quoted there
thank you thank you councillor you know
once again uh mr livingston
to come back on the benchmark land value
point um so this
is it's it's the very starting point of
the viability assessment because
often what will happen is uh applicants
will suggest the benchmark land value is
higher because they've paid too much for
the site
um and therefore they would say the
benchmark is much higher for
agricultural land
um what's been looked at by the
council's viability consultants as part
of
the local plan is looking at a specific
rate of 100 000 per acre
and that is including what the
government require
which is a premium on top of the actual
value of the agricultural land of 11 11
you know a thousand per acre and allows
for the uplift
and the expectation of housing but also
includes
the obligations that are required as
part of it so that's why
the the figure of 4.7 million which has
been agreed
by um by dixon searle is has been
settled on as appropriate
that is the stance that we have taken on
other schemes
it reflects again the evidence of what's
expected as part of the whole planned
viability which is obviously looking on
a much more strategic basis but that
obviously
has been tested in terms of whether or
not the majority of developments can
provide
30 affordable housing it's on the basis
of that specific benchmark land value
the issue on this site is as we outlined
those abnormal costs which come from the
fact that there's a 25 meter land level
difference on the site
with roads needing to join from manston
road to hearthstone road
as well as the fact that this site is
allocated for 550 houses
but it can't be proposed for 550 houses
because of the very specific things that
were found
in when the detailed survey work which
always happens after a local plan is
adopted
has shown where the archaeology
specifically is what's required in terms
of surface water drainage which has
reduced the amount of capacity this site
can provide in terms of housing
and actually losing hundreds a hundred
houses
off what the site was going to provide
naturally has quite a significant impact
on the viability of the site
so um that is why the viability
evidence that's been provided which has
been tested and has we have gone back a
number of times on it
and we do consider the benchmark land
value to be
accurate and we can agree it on that
basis uh when looking for
looking at the viability assessment
thank you thank you eden
council robin yeah thank you chair um
i think it's time that we made a
decision
i'd like to make a can i hold you there
counselor or in a moment
why but i've got councillor heart oh
sorry you didn't say it i thought the
other people willing to speak sorry
you jump jump in the gun as always thank
you
councillor heart
thank you chair um there's been a lot of
debate on this one and i think a lot of
us are very upset with how this is going
to
go and how it should be decided upon
this is the report put forward by
the officers and everybody else was very
good i mean it's exceptional
i think we have to accept that we can't
do anything about the drainage they've
done a drainage assessment they believe
that's right and therefore we should
accept that
that that is not what we should be
deciding upon because that is a
a fact that can't be proven until it
floods so i mean at the end of the day
they believe that's right
with regards to um doctors and nurses
and everything else that's
beyond our control we can't do anything
about that we're deciding on
how many houses we're going to build in
this site and
the is it right that we only get 15
percent of that
gift if you wish um and i have
great concerns about this because
i know and they knew when they put the
bid in
what had to be done not that the fact
that was 515 or whatever houses was
going to be built or proposed on there
but the fact that they're going to do
400 odd
now they knew that and they're still
putting in
a deal that gives us less than 30
percent and i must admit i do agree with
a lot of the people here
today that we do have to say
enough enough we gave way on another
decision
back in on um summerstone
i think at summerson well we said yeah
we'll accept that this time i don't
think we can i think we have to stick to
our guns and say
30 is what we want we have a very poor
population here
and okay we've had a few down from
londoners coming in with all the
um let's not work in london anymore but
that doesn't put up or push up
how much people earn and it's a very
difficult and i think it's a very hard
judgment for us to make to go against
what the council say
and the council said we should accept
this because this is part of the local
plan
and i think it's a very brave decision
for us as a committee to go against that
but in my mind i think we should not
because
of drainage not because of habitat but
because there's not enough houses
for us to give to people who are in need
and i think that's the important part
that
a lot of us are taking on board and we
can accept
that if it floods then they will have to
sort it out they've worked out that it's
right it's the fact they just do not
provide the number of houses
if that means that they could provide 25
because they reduced their their 20
million they're going to get or whatever
they're going to get as
a cost or profit from building that then
so be it if they only get five million
well i think i could be wrong five
million pound thank you very much
and i think that's the way it should be
looked at you know just not take so much
profit
and just give the rest to us yeah thank
you
yeah uh thank you very much uh council
heart counselor wing
i can't see you hank no go i i don't
mind
council wing thank you
it's the uncertainty around this that
really gets me so if i get this right
we're giving permission
to a developer to build some houses to
then sell on
so we don't know what the new developer
will actually
decide they want to do whether they're
going to come back to planning
to put in some alternative plans ask for
more houses less houses
the other cons i share all the concerns
i simply don't buy that
no wildlife a survey finds no wildlife
on that site i
absolutely find that unbelievable and if
i go back to the flooding
it's all very well saying they will have
to deal with it but it won't be those
people that will have to deal with it it
will be the people who live in those
houses and it will be
tdc and it will be kcc as mentioned
previously there remains a considerable
flood risk and given the
the recent and ever-growing problematic
situation of southern water discharging
into the sea
an increase in housing numbers seventeen
thousand
climate change that will mean more rain
and rises in sea levels
that will that are well evidenced by kcc
has this been modeled
to future proof any housing or even or
even
work out whether this development is
viable within the lifespan of the houses
it's all very well to quote provisions
and conditions
but the reality for us people and
residents that live in thani by
developments
is that some of sometimes these
provisions
and conditions are never met i talk
about
trees that are in that are in
applications that never ever appear
in the final development so i have great
concerns and i won't be supporting this
either
thank you
thank you councillor wing uh councillor
joe payford apologize
thank you chair as members will be aware
i
was against refusal of this application
at the last
meeting um it's for outline only
many of the issues um up for concern
would be dealt with then when it comes
back with reserve
for reserve matters um as far as i'm
concerned
in the original report and this current
report
all the issues of concern have been
addressed
including flooding lack of gps which are
not for us to decide tonight
however i have to accept that most
people don't feel the same way
what i do feel is that we should at
least be guided by
our planning officers about the reasons
that we give
cogent reasons so that if as we say
we risk losing on appeal we don't
risk having to pay costs as well so i
think we should listen to what they have
to say
thank you very much for that council
bayford
um councillorman i'm going to draw a
line under that and i'm not being rude
to you because i wouldn't dream of doing
that
but i think not in public anyway now i
know that
i think three meetings uh the debate
we've had tonight
i'm going to put this two members which
is have it again
thank you uh then see you there
councillor hopkins
new glasses carry on
that's all right sorry okay um yeah i
just wanted to ask
in in 2.8 i mean i i do share
a lot of the concerns in particular the
affordable housing one in 2.8 we were
given some information about a local
sorry not a local but a recent appeal
which is relevant some of the conditions
are the same but i was i was just
wondering um
because there's no context there to what
extent that's representative
of of similar appeals generally because
we're only just you know
just given told that that one appeal did
happen um so i just wondered if
you'd be able to give us any more on
that
thank you um yeah there are a few
different appeal decisions that i think
different
people have submitted to councillors and
as part of the application but
this specific one was looked at
following
the meeting last time which was
specifically to try and see
as an instance where there was agreement
in terms of the viability evidence
about affordable housing but members
didn't consider that there was
sufficient affordable housing provided
by a scheme and on the basis of the
particular concerns that this
council and the councillors had about
lack of provision in the district
so it was to look at an example where
the evidence
said one thing that you couldn't provide
the development without
actually in that instance it was zero
affordable housing and it was to give
an idea of how an inspector looks at
these issues when weighing up the
benefits and the harm
that's why it was included because in
that instance
um the costs on that site were actually
about remediation because it was it was
a
it was a site within the urban confines
like this is but it was one that needed
to be cleaned up so there was a quite
significant abnormal cost of doing that
in that instance
the application proposed zero affordable
housing and zero contributions
and the inspector when weighing up
considered the fact of what the council
has said about affordable housing but
considered that
the viability evidence and the benefits
of providing a site which
otherwise would not come forward for
development uh was considered to
outweigh
that harm so that's why it was provided
as an example
but also specifically to to try and
inform
the decision and the matter outlined at
2.6 which is about
members are entitled to give less weight
to the viability evidence as opposed you
know they you can
you can give less weight to it but in
this instance
the the evidence is there which means
that it does comply
with sp 23. sp 23 specifically says
go provide 30 affordable housing and
that target will only be reduced
if the applicant can demonstrate that it
would be unviable if they provided 30
that's been demonstrated so it's in
compliance with the policy
but the specific point raised to 2.6 is
to outline that actually if members
consider that actually even though that
policy has been met
there is a serious concern about
affordability for the reasons that are
outlined
uh in this report in terms of the
housing strategy and the objectively
assessed need
then you you know you are able to refuse
the application on this basis that's
outlined at 2.6
thank you uh thank you mr lewis and um
[Music]
council options okay if i just come back
quickly so i think i could have been a
bit clearer i
mean i'd fully see the relevance of that
of that this appeal case to ours
but what i meant was to what extent you
know i mean how many other appeals are
actually going on i mean
you know for example uh councillor kane
mentioned that
uh the case in islington uh you know
went to appeal but was rejected so i
mean i don't know how many of these
appeals are going on
um and i don't know you know to which to
what extent that one is representative
of what's going on broadly
um i mean there are obviously there are
hundreds of appeals that are going on in
fact there's quite significant backlog
of appeals that the planning spectra are
dealing with at the moment
um this is an issue that does come up
viability assessment so looked at
um issues of affordable housing and
provision of planning obligations is
something that is considered a lot by
the planning inspector this
is a recent appeal it was determined
literally a few days before the previous
meeting we had in june
so that's why it's been provided because
it's the most up-to-date and relevant
appeal
that we could find uh with regards to to
the issue
the one thing in addition in this
instance that is outlined in the report
is
in that instance the the the council
could demonstrate a five-year supply of
housing land
we we cannot at the moment because of
not providing and not meeting the
requirements the housing delivery test
which is why again the report does have
to outline that
so the members do have to be aware of
that fact if they are going to refuse it
on on the basis of
the reason given thank you chair thank
you ian
okay members um as i was saying i think
uh
after three meetings uh yourselves
um the debate has been very good
um totally understand people's concerns
um i also would like to thank the
officers for
their reports uh particularly this one
as
has been said already from council ghana
very detailed that's what you asked for
uh but therefore i i'm going to put to
members
um the option of
4.1 now i'm not sure if members have the
options
in front of them but i will read this
out and i will be looking for a proposal
for one is for members to refuse the
application
on the lack of sufficient affordable
housing as
outlined at 2.6 in
the report proposed by councillor alban
can i have a second
please counselor heart
thank you
[Music]
there yes
option 4.2 as i suggested earlier then
we need to vote against 4.1
[Music]
yes you're right yes
i i put 4.1 to yourselves at the moment
i'm not sure how many people have got
the options in front but i'm quite happy
to read them out
okay okay
i
sorry i'm just i wonder how this
actually works then because
so if we vote we vote for if we have a
vote on 4.1 reject it
on because we want to see whether or not
we might go for 4.2
i mean is there any is it possible to go
back to 4.1 or 4.2 it doesn't
come because i just it just seems to me
the problem with the the order here i
mean if you've got
basically if you've got a preference
that you want 4.2 as your first choice
of 4.1 is your second
i just wonder if the weight the
mechanism we're going to use is going to
allow us to
express that order of preference
i'm asking mrs livingston to come back
on that one counselor
thank you it's it's not a unfortunate
it's not a question of preference
it's the motion that um has been uh to
propose and second is as as councillor
ghana said
he's on the basis that the application
will be refused solely
on the affordable housing issue if that
is voted down
because members consider that um one of
the other options
is what they would want to happen then
it would be
effectively to vote against that that
motion
and then it will be about finding a new
motion to propose
um and then that will then be a motion
that's then subsequently voted on
um so it is about deciding on
specifically
on the the motion that's in front of of
members first
thank you thank you
and then it was overtaken by the debate
yes
yes he came in after him after
yes
yes to your question earlier can we
re-read the
four options please i know if we had
different i can i can
i can't you i can't find them but silly
thank you
well it's only thousands of pages here
i'm
struggling i'm going backwards and
forwards yeah
thank uh mr livingston is going to take
the blame for that
okay members um i put option 4.1 to use
let's say it's been proposed and
seconded
which and i read i will reach out again
to you now please vote on this
if you're for or against uh members
refuse the application on the lack of
sufficient affordable housing
as outlined in the report 2.6
those in favor of that option please
show your hands
yes i am fully yes
did you put your hand up i think you
better do it again yes i will thank you
thank you
those in favor sorry there's a miscount
there
against
two ascensions
two thank you that that motion
therefore is carried
okay members we've moved
thank you members um thank you members
of the public we haven't finished our
meeting tonight
um and i think as i said this has been
extensively uh debated and thank you
very much everyone
um if members of the public wish to le
and the other councillors wish to leave
we'd just have five minutes the result
i is refused
if members of the public didn't hear i
will read
it the motion 4.1
is to refuse the application on the lack
of sufficient affordable housing
as outlined at 2.6 in the main
report
i know don't don't i've got to stage
with
where i print off what i need to you
know
um
you for your help by the way
that's what i said to you earlier
these groups are popping up everywhere
thank you members uh if your patience
there and uh
let's throw one with his shorts on i'll
ask him to stand up in a minute
um right agend agenda item
six um his schedule of planned
applications and public speaking
if there are any site visits members
they will be on friday the
6th of august if there is anything quite
an outing for us as we have been out
for a long time um agenda item
6a you see a plan application
for approval of forrester's arms in
48 boundary road ramsgate
speaking in favor of the application is
mr oliver still here
thank you mr oliver i'm sorry we've kept
you quite some time
right you have three minutes please
thank you um this
application the current application um
the original was approved for
dwellings as opposed to back to a pub
however the current owners
want to keep it as a community problem
um
the the main issues that i've seen
arising are
to do with people not quite
understanding whether it's a pub
whether it's houses whether it's flats
and i couldn't just i'd just like to
assure everyone it's turning back to a
pub
um not a nightclub
not a fast food restaurant not anything
else it's just
solely a pub for the current
owners um it's been a pub since
1860 i believe overall there abouts
the current owners boarded knowing it
was a pub
but also knowing there was an
application in converted into houses
which got rejected i believe two to
three times
so their their view on it all was to
keep it as a pub
for the community to give employment to
certain people for the community
um and that's really all i've got to say
on the matter
uh thank you mr oliver i can't imagine a
nightclub in boundary road
exactly
[Music]
speaking raising points of concern
is mrs hankinson mr hankinson
yes um i'm concerned
of the garage that they are um
it was a workshop and they're converting
into a garage
now at the moment when they pull their
car out it they drive it right up to the
front of my house
the road is so terribly narrow
um and yes it was approved
for a two bed and a three bed property
and i have an article here from fanny
extra 9th of march
and saying that it was going to be
houses
not a public house
so therefore i am in disagreement with
it
and they've also done a lot of building
work which i don't think they've been
permitted to do
i'm sure that will be looked into but uh
thank you very much
mrs hankinson um mr levinson
i believe you're giving the report
yes thank you
yes sorry could you push the button to
turn your microphone off please
thank you thank you chair
um so the application site is outlined
in red the application is for the
direction of
a two-story rear extension a part single
store extension
uh with formation of parking uh
following
uh demolition of structures at the rear
of the the building
so the proposal would alter the public
house which has been closed since uh
2018
there's this isn't applying for a change
of use the use is still as a public
house
so it's not considering the actual
principle of that use
the extensions that are occurring would
alter the pub
but also extend the existing flat that
are on the upper floor of the of the
building
so going through some aerial photographs
you can see uh in the
image here the the roof plan so you can
see at the rear of the building
a number of single story structures that
are present at the moment
to give you the angled view so this is a
view looking towards
alma road from the east of the site
and then looking back to to boundary
road
so you're looking in if you can see
where the mouse pointer is members
you're looking in the around the center
of the image to the existing
single story structures and then in this
view
just turning again around the corner so
we're now looking from the north
you can see at the moment the presence
of a an extension
on the neighboring property to
forester's arms
but then you can see a view on alma road
with the structures which pretty much
cover the entire footprint of the site
with a little courtyard in the middle
at the moment so this is the property
itself so we're gonna go down armor road
to look at what's there so
um this is the single story side element
of
the the building so as mentioned there
has been some building works that has
occurred
on the the site um so
this uh and there'll be another view in
a second
on the right hand side shows an increase
in the height of
the existing side element of the
building now this element is not
within the application so it will
separately require
planning consent so we're not
considering what's been built
on that part of the site but the
proposal would demolish
the existing garage that's there and
workshop use
and create a vehicular parking for two
parking spaces you can see there's
already a drop
curb that's there for the garage and
there are already yellow lines in front
of it as well and you can see obviously
parking that's occurring
at the front of the neighboring property
so this is looking back towards
the building itself you can also see
that the rear extension that
is considered being considered by
members deceiving
has indeed also already been constructed
and has
block work um that that's present
you can also see how it relates to the
neighboring property which has
an extension of first floor level so you
can see it's not protruding
past that first floor extension on the
neighbor
and then this is a view further down
again just showing how exist
how the moment the garage at the back
there
um steps out from the neighboring
property that's the element here that's
that's to be demolished
as part of this proposal so this is the
site
in yellow and then
this is the proposed roof plan for the
development
so we'll look at this in a bit more
detail closer up you can see where those
parking spaces are present where the
garage unit was
and the roof form shown as a hipped roof
comes out from the back of the building
in line with
the extension on the the neighboring
property
so just looking at the front elevation
this plan
does include on it an internal
illuminated sign that needs
separate advertisement consent again not
for consideration in this application
members would not be approving it as
part of
this scheme um the rear elevation
at the when the application was
submitted and rephrased
um what's being proposed um is for an
extension to come out so it's not the
full width of the property
um but it's coming out um in the area in
the the center of the site so it's set
in from
armor road then this is the side
elevation from
armor road itself so you can see the
side elevation of that
first floor extension that the neighbor
has
and the proposal would be in line with
that extension but with a hipped roof
on it um there
and then this is the internal side
elevation so we're seeing a section
through the building which is obviously
attached to the neighbor
you can see that that is then the extent
of the extension but as outlined in the
photos
it doesn't protrude past the neighboring
first floor so you wouldn't ever see
this elevation
because of what's already been
constructed next door
um i'm sorry that's just a repeated one
of the other innovations so
um the existing plan of the pub is on
the left hand side of the
image and the proposed plan for the pub
is on
the right hand side so what you will see
in the center of the rear area
what currently you have a structure that
covers some toilets on the left hand
side here and the seating area
has a courtyard and then has some other
toilets
what's being proposed is that there is
an extension a ground floor
in the center of the site so to remove
some of that courtyard
there's also an extension single story
on the the right hand side of the image
here
to replace the store that's currently in
situ
and then what's happening at the rear is
a garden
is being created by virtue of the
demolition
that's occurring with parking for two
spaces
uh being proposed with a fence across
the site
and this is the elevation showing
basically what you would see
with internal on the on the on the right
hand side but just showing the height of
the fence which was a two meter high
close ball defense at the rear of where
the parking area is
the first floor plan again just shows
the extension to the
residential property upstairs to create
a a sort of new lounge to extend that
into a two bed unit
and then this is just the roof plan
showing the proposal
so the main issues for members to
consider is the impact on the character
appearance of the area
uh the impact on living conditions of
neighboring properties and also the
impact on
highway safety now in terms of
the concerns the officers had initially
it was to do with the arrangement of
parking
as proposed so what was um originally
proposed
um sorry let's click through i'll go
back now
to find the actual plan showing the site
it's
this one here um so there was a concern
about the size of the spaces originally
three spaces were proposed and they were
too small
and highways raised a concern even
though this is a what's referred to as a
non-protocol application so i always
wouldn't normally comment on it
we sought the highway view because of
our concerns about it and they did
confirm
that the spaces that were provided
wouldn't be big enough so that's where
they've reduced it to two spaces
specifically
um with larger spaces to accommodate
vehicles again the drop kerb is already
present on the site with the garage
that's there
um also there are concerns for
environmental health that even though
the whole site is covered in terms of
cartilage at the rear
um as you know as a as effectively a a
public house the creation of a garden
um at that area which currently has just
got single-story structures on it
um could lead to noise and disturbance
uh for residents there and so there is a
specific condition
put on the application that the gate
effectively be locked at 930 and you
can't use that garden
after 9 30 which is the issue that
environmental health raised so then that
is conditioned as part of
the application so overall
the application is recommended for
approval
as it's considered the design wouldn't
be significantly harmful to the
character appearance of the area
the extension itself doesn't extend past
the neighboring property to cause an
impact in terms of sense of enclosure
or outlook and doesn't create any more
overlooking and also the highway safety
issues have been dealt with by virtue
of the change in the amount of parking
thank you
excuse me may i speak i'm afraid not
madam no i'm afraid not i move the
officer's recommendation
be adopted because why chair please
second
or second nature thank you uh members
do i council robin yeah thank you chair
um i called this application in
excuse me uh steve can could you thank
you
can you press your button on you
thinking yeah
yeah uh i'll start again chair thank you
chair um
i called this up this application in on
contact from residents in
alma road who were concerned one of
which was
mrs hankinson
i went to the site yesterday and had a
look and
wasn't pleased to see that there is a
first floor extension already gone up
and the building on the side has already
gone up but as we know we can't
that's not an issue for us to discuss
this evening however what it does
what it does say to me is
should we grant consent for this you
know in and
in relation to conditions uh is there
any trust there that they're actually
did they just gone ahead and built what
they wanted to build
and are they going to comply with the
conditions anyway
um my concerns were on the over
development of the site
and uh also the main thing
really was the the parking and the
highway issues
i'm very pleased to see that it's going
to remain as a pa as a public house
as i said as uh as the gentleman said
there it's been one since about 1800 and
frozen to death as they say
and uh i'm i'm pleased with that but i
do
really have concerns for the residents
in relation to the garden there's never
been a garden
there there's never been a pub garden at
that public house
even since about 1900 or something
so um i'm concerned for noise i'm
concerned for a noise for them
for the neighbors and for those of you
who don't know
alma road is tiny the the
the the photographs don't actually do
an injustice if if you like for the size
of this for the size
size of the street and it's a colder
sack as well
so you if you to go down you have to go
down the bottom and hopefully you can
turn around at the bottom to come back
up
so i do have concerns about about this
chair but i want to hear what other
members have to say thank you uh thank
you councillorman
uh do any other members wish to speak
council heart
thank you chair following on from
council auburn actually my only concern
on that was the
lateness of the garden in the public
house i mean 9 30 is quite late you've
got small children
and they're next door and there's never
been a garden before um
you know i would consider sort of eight
o'clock eight thirty
to decide that would be um the licensing
okay okay if you don't mind okay
any other council fellows yeah i just
said wonder if
any conditions can be placed on the
parking area and so it's not a customer
parking area
so i mean i know alma road is very tight
what you don't want is
constant comings and goings to that
parking area which
says they're owners but if they're empty
then people using the pub are going to
be
trying to use them for
[Music]
um the the application before members
only conditions the arrangement it
doesn't condition the use
obviously it's been stated as you say
it's on the plan saying zones parking
if it was used by um custodians of
the pub um it wouldn't it's not
considered that it had a material
difference
in terms of on the road because
obviously if the parking is not laid out
according to the plans then there's a
problem there's a bridge condition
notice
in terms of this the actual highway
safety issue
in terms of parking in that area that's
exactly why highways looked at it to
make sure those spaces are big
enough so in terms of the impact of
people parking there
um there isn't anything that would be a
manifest necessary as a planning
condition
because a car parked in that place is
the same
if it's the owner or if it's the actual
custodians of of
the public house that would be there it
is also it is in a very sustainable
location it's important to know and
obviously previously the pub
had no parking attached to it so i don't
think it would be difficult to prove
there's a harm
with it with you know without it being
over available if chosen for
four members of the public chairman
sorry i'm sorry to interact once more
and i know you said i can't speak
um i'm afraid but it wasn't bad
that's the rules of the committee i'm
sorry it's funny
just want to come back on that um
obviously it is a tight road and picking
up on what the lady is saying about
i mean obviously cars coming and going
especially in the winter time it's dark
you know the cars parking in those
spaces the headlights are
you know the votes the vote is like 10
foot wide you know it's it's just
i just think it should be some sort of
stipulation on there that it's owen is
parking only and there's no coming and
going
throughout throughout the evening to
those parking spaces
i think council fellas that could be
rather
difficult um but
i think that could be under enforcement
if it has to be um
again i understand what you're getting
at are there any
other speakers okay members
um the vote is for approval
so if you are minded to approve could
you please show your hands
that includes me those against
abstentions
that has been carried thank you for that
members
uh moving on now to gender item
6 d
which is uh 49 peter's road
brawl stairs speaking in favor of this
application
is mr brown
thank you chair and members um can i
just
uh suggest a correction it's 49ers in
peter's court
not
the careful consideration of previous
outline
permitted planning and also
pre-application advice has been
considered
and as a neighbor directly adjacent to
the proposed property
we've taken careful consideration of the
impact with local
on our local neighbours the
proposed bungalow is mirroring the
bungalow opposite
the site and you'll
hopefully see that we've taken uh via
update to the planning
application consideration of the
fully consideration of the comments that
have been made by our neighbours
thank you uh thank you mr brown i will
ask once again mr livingston for his
report please
thank you chair uh the application is
for the original single story two bed
dwelling with the creation of
uh vehicular access uh just one point to
update members
the report doesn't include um a comment
from broad stairs and sir peter's town
council
they voted to refuse the application
they recommended refusal
on the grounds of crampton congested
character and impact on the character of
the area on that
basis so the main issues include
the impact on the character and
appearance of the area impact on living
conditions and impact on highway safety
is the principal issues for
consideration
so the site is outlined in red you can
see the footprint of the dwelling that's
proposed on the screen
i'm going to just go through the aerial
images of the site
um so you can see some peter's caught
there
with the uh with the sort of cul-de-sac
t shape
uh with the site uh just adjacent to
that and then going through
some of the isometric 3d views so we can
see the area
next to the property here when the photo
was
taken showing landscaping on there which
we'll look at
as a tree survey was submitted you can
see from this image that there is a mix
of bungalows directly opposite the site
and two-story properties all the very
strong gable design
nearly entirely detached or sort of
linked attached
in the road so this is another view just
showing
again the the style of property around
there
in the area and then this is
an important view to just understand the
relationship between the existing built
forms so you can see
number 49 in the center of the image and
the area of land adjacent where the
dwelling is proposed
and then this is just another angle
again showing
that specific space in the street scene
so this is the site in question so
number 49 is
on the screen and the area that would be
proposed for the bungalow
is is directly in the center of the
image
um then you can see the row of of
properties there on that side of the
road you've got
two-story properties again with that
very strong gable design
this is another view just showing the
relationship with the garage of the
neighboring property
so you can see that garage is set quite
far back into the site
and you can also see some very prominent
trees at the rear of the site
which are obviously very significant in
scale
this is directly opposite the site so
you can see that you have
a bungalow design and these are found
further up uh some peter's court as well
uh and again it's it's indicative of a
planned development that all occurred
obviously at the same time but with
the different styles shown
[Music]
and then this is just turning to your
left so it's the other end of the
t junction so you can see the
relationship between the dwelling
there being on the corner with the
garage setback
in directly opposite the site
uh and so just to confirm on the other
side of number 49 the distance between
the neighboring properties there and
then this is the last i believe there's
the last view
just showing that space from the other
angle
so as mentioned the proposal would be
for a new single dwelling in the side
garden of the property
looking at the existing site plan so
what you can see here is
the location of the existing landscaping
of the actual
actual trees that are on site so the
very significant scale trees
are at the rear of the site here so
behind the garage of the neighboring
property
and what's being proposed is that the
those dwellings sorry those trees are
being retained the boundaries being
reinforced
with a small bay tree being retained as
well and is proposed to put a dwelling
within the gap next to number 49
a key point to look at members here is
the proposal for a new
vehicular crossover which is proposing
to provide
two off-street car parking spaces there
is provision in the
garage because of its size for a parking
space within there
but um it's it's not something that
we've necessarily sort of bank on
because most people
as most people should agree garages are
often used for storage other things so
that's why it's key that in this
instance two parking spaces
are provided um so going through
the plans themselves so this is the
proposed elevation so you can see
it's matching the design of the property
opposite in terms of its style
and in a general form of being a you
know gable fronted property
with white cladding the brick is
proposed to match
the yellow stock brick on number 49
so that that you know that comes forward
on that basis the garage
on the right hand side is set far back
from the front elevation and we'll see
that when looking at the side elevation
in terms of the rear elevation that's
been proposed to be rendered
so it's not proposed to match the the
style of the front
but it's not visible for anywhere so
it's not considered that that would in
office's views have an impact on the
character appearance of the area
this is the side elevation so again
showing that the garage is actually set
quite far back on that property and
we'll look again at the site plan to
show its relationship with the existing
garage on the neighbor so you can get an
idea of where that is
and then this is the other side which
obviously would be directly adjacent to
number 49.
so this is the existing street scene um
you can see at the top that
the gap itself the distance from the
side of number 49
to the garage of number 51 so therefore
what's being proposed is to put dwelling
in that gap and again with the garage
that's there
being set far back so you would read the
the main mass of the property
as being the you know the section with
just the two windows in
there so he's considered by officers
that there is sufficient space for a
dwelling on the site there is previous
outline approval from 2004
which approved a dwelling on this site
and i'll show you the plans of that
that was approved only outline stage
though so the detailed design wasn't
fixed but the layout and
footprint of the building was uh we do
consider this is
the most appropriate solution for
developing this site as being a bungalow
to ensure that there is still um you
know there is still some space around
the property
uh it would result in the loss of open
space on that corner
but it is isn't considered to be
significantly detrimental to the overall
area by virtue of putting that on site
you can see on the bottom image as well
that the bungalow is set behind number
49
so in longer views down some peter's
core the bungalow would be
hidden behind number 49 just as the open
space
is at the moment um so again this is the
image to show um the relationship if you
look on the
right hand side members you'll see that
the garage is is there
the wall that is present which is set
forward of that garrett
is around approximately the position of
where this garage would be for the new
dwelling
so you can see that the garage would be
pretty much where the mass of
of planting is at the moment with that
brick wall with then the dwelling coming
forward but not as far forward
as number 49 so that just shows you in a
bit more detail that relationship so at
the top you've got the garage
then it steps forward for the single
story garage and then the main gable
frontage of the property
is set back from the front of number 49.
um the application isn't considered to
have a harmful impact on
the living conditions of neighbouring
properties it's
a single story with a hip roof away from
number 49
even though number 49 are the applicants
we still need to consider
the principle of putting a dwelling next
to a unit of accommodation
in case we set a precedent in terms of
the relationship between properties even
though obviously the applicant is
agreeing to this
impact in this instance it's considered
that the distance away as well as the
single story height
wouldn't result in a significant impact
in terms of sense of enclosure
because of the fact that the root the
main body of the roof hips away
and obviously the bungalow scale is
generally considered to be appropriate
in the
in terms of the impact on the rest of
the dwellings in the area
and as you saw from the close it's far
or enough away
from the other units that go around that
that t
uh junction um just to show you
um the that impact on neighbours in it
and to sign a tiny bit more detail
on the left hand side here you've got
the the layout of the ground floor
which shows the side windows for
that dwelling which obviously previously
looked into a garden
but now we'll be looking towards the
side of the new dwelling
you can see that all those windows are
secondary windows
so they've all got another window facing
forward or back
to ensure there is sufficient outlook
that they're not the primary
windows of a habitable room
in terms of the 2004 plan this is the
plan that's proved in 2004
obviously we are talking about
17 years ago so policy has changed
um the impact of the character and
appearance in its general strokes has
not changed in terms of considerations
but obviously the policies have changed
um but it's considered relevant to put
in front of members
that you know this has been approved
previously it was
approved even though it hasn't got any
elevations as a as a bungalow to be
similar design
to the ones in the road um and so it's
worth just
pointing that out to members so overall
um the application is recommended in
this instance to defer and delegate for
approval
that's because we need to secure the
contribution towards the strategic
access management
monitoring plan and therefore we've got
a draft unilateral undertaking but we
haven't got a signed unilateral
undertaking
that secures that contribution which is
why it's being delegated for approval
subject to getting that legal agreement
and the safeguarding conditions that are
attached
thank you chad uh thank you ann i move
the officer's
recommendation is adopted because the
vice chair please
second oh second nature i think accounts
of coleman cook
how's it ghana
thank you yeah thanks very much yeah i
called this
um application in um after
being contacted by a few of the
res the neighbouring residents who um
who raised some concerns about it um i
think
we as i said it was as mr liverson said
um what's missing from newport is the
the
report from the town council planning
committee who
discussed it uh quite length i'm not on
the
town council infinity but it was
discussed there and
um refused by or recommended for refusal
by the town council
um for a couple of reasons
um they felt they agreed with the
residents who'd asked me to call it in
that um the design was
as broad says society said that keeping
with the original design concept
therefore that that open
space at the one side of the hammerhead
which we saw with um with quite an
abundance of vegetation on
was part of that design for that
area um and there was also
i mean that was the main concern i think
um
but there was also concern that it was
our keeping
um with the rest of the with the rest of
the
with rest of that hammerhead um area
so um that's why i called it in here to
be
discussed because i i did share their
concerns
thank you thank you carl um
are there any other members wish to
discuss
okay thank you councilman for did you
indicate there
okay thank you yeah do you want to miss
you this time
i'm gonna end up with some chickens or
something
thank you members right i will put this
to you um
those in favor please show
myself those against
one abstentions
thank you has been carried
thank you very much members thank you mr
brown
yes so thank you to the chief executive
to keep an eye on us tonight i think so
yeah think about it
right that concludes public speaking for
this meeting
um as council heart knows he has
declared an eye
interest in item six b so
i would ask politely to counsel her
heart to
leave the chamber
keep walking
okay work i like this the way it's
written down here once counselor heart
is left i can start it going so
i will call upon the clerk um james to
read out the remaining
planning applications if there is a
member wishes to reserve
any application would they please call
out
as he reads james thank you chair so the
final two applications for consideration
this evening is
uh item 6b which is 32 shakespeare road
birchington
and item 6c which is 20 amesbury avenue
ranchgate
thank you does anybody wish to
thank you members that does conclude
this evening oh yes sorry i
always forget that piece i'm sorry yes
could i have a proposer
please for those determinations that
thank you claus allman and the seconder
council com
cook and do you agree
thank you members